so two keys huh that's a lot of snow if
you can't handle it we're happy to find
someone who can
don't worry about me front I can handle
it Marissa baby go get our guests I'm
gonna drink with you we don't want to
join or is this a social call not a tea
party like five-year-old girls -
gentlemen please have some patience
- Kies pure is a Catholic schoolgirl did
you bring the cash oh we brought
something much better than cash what's
that argon boss man's gone where'd he go
[Music]
thank you kind little lady
[Music]
gyeo Kosta you're under arrest
what that drink now Hitchcock don't mind
if I do Scully don't mind if I do
hey Jake can I show you something over
here
sure thing Webb trying to send genevieve
his sexy pic just moved my bubble butt
pop nope
I'm out meet detective Adrian pimento
he's been deep undercover for the last
12 years but he's just resurfaced and
he's rejoining the nine-nine that yes
what is it
tell me Plaza it's the most important
man you've been in all of America the
building from die hard can we go in can
we pay our respects where's flight
leaves in three and a half hours and but
it's like what is time even hashtag
legalize it can we go in sir fine just
make it quick
yes pull it over there Argyle fourth
it's the name of the driver in the movie
we're gonna dock you tell me please'
there's gonna be a role play empty floor
this under construction just like in the
movie Charles this is the floor that
John McClane ran on with his bare feet
take my picture with it
this is the window where John McClane
said welcome to the party pal take my
picture with it this is the event where
John MacLean say come out to the ghost
we get together have a few left if we
make sure that this is the space where
even though it's not really evident the
dialog you can tell John McClane
realizes he should have been a better
husband to Holly Gennaro take my picture
with it take my picture take my picture
with it
take my make sure with it I think you
could ever want to help you I appealed
to their sense of teamwork and
camaraderie with a rousing speech that
would put Shakespeare to shame so too
long we've been put down ridiculed made
to wear ties but no more for today we
defeat him and that worked no no no not
at all my speech did not inspire them
mom
so I bragged them I told them that if we
pulled this off I would do all of their
paperwork and since you are doing all my
paperwork I'm impressed by Ulta well
done thank you sir in fact the thing
that you failed to see captain captain
and so concludes this year's Secret
Santa drawings it's a quick reminder of
the rules $40 limit non perishable items
and no homemade massage coupons
Hitchcock fine that never will have to
pay full price for them Oh captain I
would like a $40 gift card to any
restaurant that serves nachos I don't
have ueberall do not only do I know that
you do indeed have me but I also know
who everyone else has
that's not possible perhaps not for
ordinary man such as yourself Jeffords
but for the brilliant mind of detective
Jacob Sherlock Peralta I legally changed
my name it's quite simply elementary for
you see Amy made a face I only recognize
from our bedroom which means that she
has captain Holt Charles has Terry his
eyes keep shifting over to him well they
know Terry looked disgusted which means
he has Hitchcock Rosa didn't draw a name
nor did she put one in she doesn't want
to participate never do Hitchcock moves
his mouth when he reads it he quite
clearly said Charlotte I did get Charlie
Scully has Amy he's holding his paper
named sideout oh he's good and I have
Scully which means captain Holt has me
I'll be taking that gift card daddy
loves nachos
shall we draw the names again and leave
Jake out yeah sure what's the present
friends colleagues gawking New Yorkers
we are here today to celebrate the
marriage of Jake Peralta and Amy
Santiago I've known you both for the
last five years and it has been a true
pleasure to watch your distracting
childish rivalry evolved into a
distracting childish courtship and now
into what I'm sure will be a distracting
childish marriage I'm proud of you and I
love you both permission to say it back
permission granted love you captain Oh
ladies and gentlemen I present Carl
Watson who stole $3,000 Santiago takes
the lead with one minute left
suck it Peralta oh no that's right oh no
oh no you don't seem worried why are you
worried bring in the Jones area
prostitution sting through Vice and
arrested 30 guys for soliciting that's
not a felony it is when it's your second
offense which is the case for ten of
these gentlemen fun fact or of them are
actually named John ironic anywho ten
more for Peralta accept your fate never
five four three two one Jake wins Amy
loses
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Amy Santiago you have made me the
happiest man on earth I spent one whole
dollar on this ring will you go on the
worst date ever with me you have to say
yes I get that the guys at our precinct
wouldn't pro follow me but it still
happened only one precinct over which is
why you need to keep pushing forward in
your career so that you can change the
system Terry you're a great cop you can
become a chief or higher how long will
it take to make change that way modak is
on the street now you know I became a
cop please share because when I was a
kid I always wanted to be a superhero
stop it stop bothering little teary or
what or I will defeat you
well I wanted to help people like that
cop helped me but right now I don't feel
like superior I feel the opposite when I
got stopped the other day I wasn't a cop
I wasn't a guy who lived in a
neighborhood looking for his daughter's
toy I was a black man a dangerous black
man I saw he could see a threat and I
couldn't stop thinking about my
daughter's in their future and how years
from now they could be walking down the
street looking for their kids muumuu and
get stopped by bad cop and they probably
won't get to plate a police car to get
out of trouble unlike that thought I'm
not gonna do something about it so I
don't care if it might hurt my career
I'm filing that report even if I have to
go over your head to do it kind of seem
like you're gonna get up leave after
saying all that os I think I hear Marco
bowels oil bullpen
what are you bottles boil bull been
bowling behold
Brooklyn buddies Boyle bullpen bottle
bowling beautiful be brave bro be brave
[Music]
oh yeah I'm Philip Davidson detective
take profit asked me to drop by Oh the
dentist who murdered someone spoiler
alert they think you did it can you show
him to interrogation room C please have
fun in there
thank you what he smiling about how
uncomfortable this guy is jacked up the
thermostat got the table all sticky made
one of the chair legs too short and
worst of all I had Gina greet Emma what
did you ever do be yourself poor son of
a [ __ ] yeah why are you wearing a
tuxedo Kevin and I are attending the
Opera the Opera is that the one Bugs
Bunny sings yes
okay so who's this this is Philip
Davidson where we have a clear motive
clear means and a non-existent alibi but
the DA won't bring a charge because he
says it's all circumstantial we want to
bring this guy down we have to get him
to confess right here right now mmm
interrogation with a ticking clock
and everything on the line I better call
Kevin and tell him I won't be attending
the Opera there's someone else I'd
rather hear sing oh hello Kevin I won't
be joining us
you